t
des élections, la cheffe
du Parti libéral dévoile déjàavs
elle espère séduire
les Québécois.
Son message est clair :
Legault, elle verra venir
s s s crises, et saura
y réagir.
DOMINIQUE ANGLAD
cheffe, Parti libéral du Québec
- On l'a vu avec la crise
du logement, on le voit avec
la question de la main-d'oeuvren
du coût de la vie.
Toutes les mesures qu'ils
prennent sont des mesures
- En réplique au fameux chèque
de d d dollars, Dominique
Anglade propose de baisser
les impôts de 1,5 s s s s s s se
la classe moyenne.
Une aide à long terme,
qui leur rapporterait jusqu'à
mille dollars par année.
présentement, c'est une crise
qui dudududurer. Demain matin,
les gens qui ont de la misère
à joindre les deux bouts,
à payer pour l'épicerie, ça va
pas partir après six mois,
pas partir après un an.
Regardezles loyers...
- Enrararararararararararararare
mesure, mais le contexte
a changé : l'économie ralentit,
l'inflation est galopante.
CARLOS LEITAO, porte-parole
- On a amplement de marge de
manoeuvr f f f faire ce qu'on
veut faire. Et en faisant
ce qu'on propose, on va aussi
- Le Parti libéral du Québec
est capable de se renouveler.
(applaudissements)
- Personne ici n'ignore que
de face. Les récents débats
sur la langue française
ont fragilisé son lien avec
L'aiguille des sondages,
déjà basseààààà remonter.
Mais les militants
s'accrochent...ALALALALALALALALt
Parti libéral du Québec
- Il faut être optimiste,
il ne faut pas se fier
SAMIA SIDAWI, militante, PLQ
- Il y a toujours des hauts
et des bas, mais on est là quand
c'est en bas pour remonter!
- Sur unuxuxuxuxuxuxuxuxuxuxuxut
d'accueillir 70 000 immigrants
l'an prochain avant d'aller
consulter les régions
po
d'accueil.
- On va être la gééééé
en opposition au repli.
- Le Parti libéral n'est pase er
ses promesses. Mais en
les dévoilant maintenant,
Dominique Anglade fait le pari
d'avance sur ses adversaires
l l l l l les électeurs
connaissent ses idées.
Ici AlexandrRaRaRaRaRaRaRaRaRl